let me just oh I'm gonna try to be a
distraction so go into like some deep
corner and drop me off not near the
juice I'll run around it out you got
right here yeah I hear right here I got
right now so I'm gonna run around I
don't think I have a gun at all oh I do
have guns okay oh shoot gun is back -
yeah I don't think I have guns is the
fact that you're gonna die right now
no I've got no jet jet I want you
wait Jack we have a jet okay I'm gonna
hot water like a cop real try to get
into it I'm such an idiot
oh that's a tank Oh God dang boy die yes
I did the jet you [ __ ] get in the jet Oh
doc you know there's a frickin tank on
my ass uh miss me you miss me okay you
miss me okay I'm good I'm good oh no SUV
so I can ride with you guys
all right wait I'm coming back with a
car so if it unless anyone else kits in
it should have a no - wait wait wait Oh
pickup truck it's got forced laugh [ __ ]
you mini oh oh oh oh I didn't kill the
other guy before I got in the tank I
almost had a tank you weren't trying to
get in the tank I almost had a tank I
almost had a tank I sorry I've got a
four-seater Wade I've got a pickup truck
let's do this do not go Matt use a mini
to get in they shook I'm coming I did
right behind your mama oh hey Mark do
you want a ride yeah go up the help Baba
love you Bob loves oh why not run you
over
whoa wait whoa wait whoa Jesus hey I
don't like how this all turned into
everybody here's Jack well you made it
this way you made the bet man yeah man
they made it against Marcus he took up
the bet you a Lakers Highway wait we're
in a pickup truck what are you doing I
thought I was excited he was steps from
our car oh hi uh care to lay this have
it's too late still oh wait we can do it
you know find mr. there's a truck there
okay if this power won't get up I'm not
letting you guys get off haha
I'm a stop I don't think you could stop
us jack I'm sorry you guys I have a mini
it's very powerful [ __ ] you
oh no no mark don't get us stars we're
trying to [ __ ] do some oh I already
got a star sorry to do that okay mean
it's not really gonna hurt we're already
here so no wait no take it in no I get
my own thing you will get me killed
that that is correct way to get people
killed prove me wrong way to prove me
wrong I can't you won't regard you ready
ready ready ready let's do this
yes can't do this before right yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm livin face it
oh god jokes okay we got a kill oh here
I gotta get a gun I gotta get a tank
there way please I've got 12 bullets to
get a gun so I'll get out right here
here again yeah here again I'm gonna all
right a gun yeah wait I give you
coverage just just blow up just don't
blow up yet I will I will make a loop
and I will try and stay alive [ __ ] you
guys I'm in now as well
games on games on Jack oh yeah I'm here
come flight it Shane we didn't even get
to cut didn't even kill a guy I failed
I'm dead oh god damn it right then you
help me out ah get in the jet no get up
you dumb [ __ ] no mom no mom no bother
go ahead nobody be bad ah [ __ ]
yeah wait
none of Jack sorry Jack you're such a
huge Jack Lana kill you when we get this
jet we're gonna kill you Oh Bosley my
jet won't move
oh no you get for being a [ __ ] ya
masturbate song ah what happened how did
all three of us die separately at once
Bob I'm sorry Mini Coopers are stupid
anywho / suck my manicure like took one
ramp and then just exploded
right here in a truck no I'm gonna go in
a separate one just cos got a good [ __ ]
no no
I got it okay the man for himself yeah
exactly every man for himself
[ __ ] you guys I'm gonna [ __ ] look look
go Bob hovering over the military base
just you hand it to me don't you shoot
you and all over the gun out and shot me
don't throw the army going don't run out
of five thousand has been set on me what
oh yeah that was not me wait mark laughs
really sinister right as that happens I
know go ahead with as much it happened
like hey I don't trust mark be able to
know mr. clever plan so man I think I
got a gun I got a gun okay I got a gun
sweet got a gun all right I'm gonna do
this [ __ ] get in quickly jerk
we got stairs and I'm very low health Oh
Oh what I picked the right driver yep
okay I'm half hello oh my god car rolled
over that Karthik so bad so much head we
got this wait I'm in the lead [ __ ]
I am actually a little bit appreciative
that you could object I'm substantially
in the lead and they get into jewelry
you shot it by tanks killing you didn't
help me anyway cuz I blocked the jet for
myself and I couldn't get out [ __ ]
I'm having trouble just getting over the
hill so if you guys could give me a
little bit and wait for me that'd be
really nice
ah no no I don't feel like it [ __ ] are
you I'm about to get a chair patrols Oh
Cal there I open the chair and go just
fly oh god my eyes wait don't even
[ __ ] worry about it
tank [ __ ] you are you sink oh no no no
no no no oh my god oh yeah
I parked the ground that I have to get I
had a jet in the air how do i do how
close is that you need to actually get
it and control it yeah and it slowly
shut down right away lying it in the air
off the ground alright nice graph got it
they lit [ __ ] well okay like I think we
need like it oh honey Armour something
because this is
work does lamination near this place oh
I [ __ ] hate [ __ ] Omo dick give me
your good gotta kill this guy
now get out wait out even though I
should just take the jet kill you
what well I I it's well the hostility
ammunation where is you oh yeah
mark is that you no no no no no [ __ ] no
oh gods my god no one's here
oh there's more tanks oh this is bad
oh I don't like this is hard
yeah yeah I'm starting to suspect that
none of us are ever going to get a jet I
[ __ ] had one all the righthand how do
we get like guns and stuff do you have
to have levels um you can steal them
from dead people like if you kill if you
can kill a military guy you could
probably pick up his guns but it's hard
to do first guns you might be able to
buy it I know that pain Jack I know that
pain if why did it take so long to get
into the Jets how fine wait what the
hell throne button yeah
wait let's go get some guns we're gonna
get this know put on the map not even on
the map you can follow me yeah whole
Jack Holmes over there other way Jack
Wade completely opposite way nobody
knows I'm here alright you're all being
clever oops
jet [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
wait don't okay Wow oh [ __ ] you got a
bob get a jet for us how do you
knowledge it I'm in this dress you got a
jet
I wanna Judd I don't know how to make
the landing gear go up but I have a jet
F stick click oh hey there it is thanks
jack hey I'm on a keyboard I have no
idea what it is hunky come shoot us down
Bob no no no
do it yeah well bring it on we got guns
you got not guns
this way yeah there's an ambulance is
way wait I thought there was an
ammunition up that way why do I have a
purple map marker there's one either
direction you guys can go to that one
wait everything you've done
BAM okay towards that way I just GPS
Navy nation you guys are all cutting out
a little bit for me
that's what happens hello let's that's
life is that you jack
thank you Bob I wouldn't thank me yet
Jack ah [ __ ] you David Bob
oh Jesus oh where am I now how's it
going wait I need a bank I have no money
I've got all my money in my bank
oh no airplane well why kill him I'm
fine I'm fine it's okay airplane oh okay
really worried about you Bob the [ __ ]
ammunition guy killed me Oh suck on all
of my testicles oh I'm s
Oh No oh there's trees and [ __ ]
Oh God hey Bob is that a two-seater
plane there nothing getting a little bit
let's do anyway marks go to get into one
oh yeah my screen
oh man owes Oz up close on that one Oh
ba ba ba ba ba ba
Bob kill him again thing what are you
doing why not doing I'm not doing much
of anything I go for a bank I don't have
money those right in front of me well if
your jet is gonna give up before you get
the oh it's about to explode I don't
think I'm gonna be able to kill you jack
I am the sneaky assassin ah [ __ ]
emulation guy you suck a big dick that
the rocket launcher on it mean - where
are you fellers at okay okay yes like a
lemon
can [ __ ] wait do you guns can I steal
your guns no ammunation is closed
why you have to have no wanted level I
think yeah and don't have a gun out oh
yeah if you have a gun out they they
think you're trying to rob them I put
your dick away they don't like that
they're there Lester murdered it there
yeah me oh and I got I got a go
somewhere apparently ha ha ha uh how you
doing fellers well good
look out ways to bleed what are you
doing vade stop time please [ __ ]
leave and take the cops with you I need
ammo he's just watching my car let me
just oh I'm just looking there we go god
damn it Wade I like over like a prayer
like a please do it oh no no this is the
furthest I've made it yet with you Jack
don't
her Bob don't kill Bob no real good
fellers know where Bob Bob know what's
fun it's like a fun road trip you got
going on my I need to steal some stuff
in here wait why are you gonna steal
some stuff in here
did you guys see this [ __ ] no whatever
ow ow ow
Rory's you blossom is Rule three